give this guy hands up we can tell me
sane 30 by the way it's not easy get
tired of it oh ha very good thank you
this is the one where you should be like
right away I know this one ok but just
as a side note whatever quit a teacher
has a bunch of questions for you and
then I go of all the tears volunteers
always go early go early because it gets
it always gets progressively harder you
might as well get it out of the way side
60 a bit trickier yeah ok ok you can do
it as a decimal so your point in 66 but
you remember these guys are special
because we can get exact values we don't
need to resort to decimals we can have
some square roots and serves ok so 0.86
six what surd easier equal to David
Brinkley on two fantastic ok now sign
240 don't shout out yet but who's got
signed to 40 heads up I can't decent
number of you ok so Kyle asked what did
you get for it negative root 3 on 2
she's exactly right now you should be a
little suspicious for those of you who
well I do where did that come from ok I
paired up some of these solutions said
they help you get they help you one will
help you calculate another write em down
exercises and the tens will often do
this so you see these two right 6240 are
conditioned to each other let me help
you remember how I'll put this over here
with the right Kabaddi if you remember
back to the unit circle right and if you
if you're the in the group where you
kind of looked at this you've got I
don't know to do at all ok maybe you
want just quickly jot one of these down
with me does it have to be beautiful
we're not going to put a whole amount of
it just enough to answer this question
that's all 60 at children 40 they're
closely related okay 60 degrees is
exactly how much less than 240 what's
the difference
280 degrees right so 180 degrees is that
as a straight line so these are
important angles right if I go to my
unit circle where is 60 degrees where do
we start measuring from which site I've
got a one two three four places I could
start measuring from which one of them
do I take I take I take the fourth 100
into this one over here and you would
call that we named this rally beauty
because it's the x axis but it's the one
of the plus side we call it being a
positive x-axis so that's where I begin
60 degrees if I believe he is going to
go something like that that looks like
about 60 degrees to be okay and so
remembering that your x and y
coordinates of cos and sine that's how
we redefine the trig functions right X
will be closed 60 I don't really want
but the Y will be sine 60 which is root
3 okay and you can see by the way it's
kind of K adventure to us point eight
six six point eight six six one is right
up there right yeah point eight six six
is pretty high it's pretty close to one
now i'm going to use this as much
stepping stone to the next one right 204
degrees we just told me you just told me
that it's 180 degrees different from 60
180 degrees so that means i get this
straight line going all the way over
there right sorry monkey
okay there's the first 60 that I put on
there and then I add a hundred eighty so
now all the way around agree that's my
240 degrees okay and I'm still asking
about science so I'm still interested in
the y-coordinate right so I've got this
could have been caused to 40 so 240 okay
now again the circle what's special
about is it symmetrical it's symmetrical
everywhere right so can you see you can
even look at it if you draw reasonably
accurately right this y coordinate up
here which we have is route 302 is going
to be exactly the same button upside
down it's okay it's not the first time
but upside down foot for this guy down
here right you see that right dump it if
that's rude three-on-two up the top they
were going to get negative bring up two
down the bottom okay one more trick
remember if you haven't already grabbed
your calculator out too close when you
pop in sine 60 right I showed you this
trick before it's a bit of a half but
sometimes when you to pitch a hack is
better than nothing right when you put
in sine 60 and it provides you that
decimal mates at point eight six six if
you go ahead and you put inside 240
it'll give you the same decibel but with
a minus sign at the front which is it
surprising is it wants you to be
yourself okay so you can use that to
your advantage of course you can do one
more thing you can square it and what
would you expect to get before you press
equally when you square this guy the top
wake up three and the bottom will become
4 so you're expecting three quarters
right which sure enough 0.75 okay so
that was just for me right cause 45 who
can give me cos 45 somebody hasn't said
anything yet you don't got that heads up
yeah back
all very close one over its root 2 isn't
it so very close right and the way you
can confirm for yourself because that's
the tricky is number one chuck it in
your calculator right that will give you
a shot or you can draw that triangle
this guy 11 and Pythagoras will tell you
what the hypotenuse is it true too okay
so very close but always remember um
you've got plenty of these two healthy
check now again just like with two and
three I paired up four and five okay so
close 315 you can see there's a
relationship here between 45 and 350
right let me check it on a on another
unit circle are you getting the sense
yet unit circles are really useful okay
oh where would 45 degrees bed again
it'll be out up here in this first
quadrant so this is 45 350 350 goes all
the way around to hear you see that
right I'm 45 degrees short of coming
back to the start because pay back to
start is 360 right so going all the way
around that's 350 okay you already told
me what cause 45 is right that's up here
cause 45 and the x coordinates sorry the
wife will be starting point 5 so that
guy's water route to ya where's 315 he's
directly below right so he should share
the same x-coordinate right this cause
if you see sign 350
these guys should be identical any
points on the Cartesian plane that are
directly above one another or below one
another they should share the same x
value right and sure enough if you chuck
it into your calculator dv8 10.7 ish for
this and you should get the same number
by 3 15 right so what aren't you are you
happy with that make sense all right
who's got some answers for six or seven
for those quadratics someone has to say
anything yet so was it good it Aaron I
mean oh the first value for x yeah yeah
okay who has the same on top yes okay
now how do we get there be that that's
correct how do you actually like do I
just pop numbers in and see what happens
what what technique should I use I
should factor I should know okay so
let's just quickly factorize this guy
together I'm searching for a pair of
numbers what are the pair of numbers do
special mother they should they should
multiply to give me negative 4 and they
should add to give me three how we did
okay so therefore when I do this the two
numbers add 2 3 multiplied a you for the
pair of dog is going to be X minus 1 x
plus 4 does it work yeah this is what it
does right you can quickly go back and
test your life or miss negative one band
4 times negative 1 and it works okay and
straight out of there you can get your
solutions right okay moving on to
seventh you can do the same kind of
thing right Joey go back don't you go
back sorry we got yeah yeah 4-1 ok you
mean for the final on top yeah did you
get this yeah okay all right that's a
great question asked what's because i'm
going to use it again so i might as well
clarify it out how did i get from here
up to here what is it that when i have x
minus 1 the answer is not minus 1 okay
let me try and explain if i tell you if
i tell you I've got a young still over
here I had a pair of numbers a and B
okay and if i multiply them together
then i get 0 now immediately without
knowing anything else about this pair of
numbers right you know at least one of
them maybe both of them it should be
boring okay at least one of these
numbers has to be 0 right because if you
take any other numbers like 1 and a
hundred or 5 and negative 3 or 50
billion and a half right doesn't matter
what numbers you combine if one of them
isn't zero then your product can't
possibly be 0 so one of them's gotta be
0 does that make sense
okay so let's just suppose let's suppose
it's the first one okay now over here I
know doesn't look like it but this is
exactly the same situation I have a pair
of numbers one of them is X minus one
and the other one is X plus 4 and
apparently if i multiply them just like
over there I'm going to get zero so I
know that one of them or both of them
have to be zero so let's take this one
at a time let's try this guy right
suppose that number on the left hand
side a right suppose he is 0 so X minus
1 equals 0 this is what I'm testing out
okay now I know there's only one way
that I can put a value in for X that
will make this work right if you think
back to equations what will I do to both
sides of the equation to solve this
thing I'm going to add one plus one of
those science right which gives me x
equals positive one not negative 1 it's
kind of the reverse isn't it right and I
can do exactly the same thing over here
suppose I was wrong maybe it's like this
guy 0 maybe it's this guy ok so I'll say
X plus 4 let's try that guy be easier
well thinking equations what will I do
to both sides to make X subject the
answers I'll take away 4 right you take
away for from this side just leaves you
with X you take away for from this side
is you negative or rather than positive
4 ok another way of seeing it is that
suppose I did say you don't diss this I
was trying to do this all in my head and
I wrote down x equals negative 1 or 4 ok
i can try both of those values i can pop
them back in here or i can pop the bead
here and something will break like I'm
gonna get let's see it's trying to give
1 negative 2 times 3 which is negative 6
it's not a zero it doesn't satisfy the
original equation ok so there are two
ways now that i know this way here that
I've written in green or just by testing
out when i get to see have I got it
right or not it's one of the really
important things in both not just to be
able to get me at art of yoga convince
yourself and others it's the
one is that a little clearer all right
excellent um being they'll spend a bit
of time on that let's just do this one
really quickly what should I do to both
sides to meet to video I'll take away 6
from both sides I am space oh yeah that
gives it is and again we're going to
such that pair of numbers right what's
the pair of numbers it's going to be
it's almost five or two is it when i add
five and two I don't get three I get
seven so one of these numbers has to be
negative right one of the five I guess
it'll be negative 25 minus 2 WB 3 and 5
times negative 2 that'll give me
negative so this will be my
factorization UK with that let me get
some more space underneath here just
like i went from this factorization to
the solutions right I'm going to do the
same thing for this peg here which will
give me x equals one of my two solutions
yeah negative 5 or two babe I'm done
okay and of course you can go back you
can check it out pop it in here you can
pop a ride back to the side if you like
let's see here okay let's try to get at
five shall we negative 5 squared when
you square what happens to the negative
cancels itself out so you're 25 plus
this is going to become negative 15 so
that becomes 25-15 that's tap your
takeaway for 10 take away 4 is 6 now
with that's fine okay and you can go
ahead and do the same thing like to